qu'elle étudiera mérite de cette
commission a jusqu'à présent parce que
j'en avais fait je pense que c'est
devoir confirmer ce que vous vous aviez
trouvé et de l'avs ont mis au grand jour
et que ça ne reste plus à l'état de
spéculation ou délégation mais qu' il
soit établi qu'il y avait des système de
collusion dans l'octroi des contrats d
répartition entre firmes de construction
entre firmes de génie qui avaient des
violations de la loi sur la concurrence
au niveau de la fixation des prix au
niveau de la fixation des soumissions
publiques
donc je pense que ça a mis tout cela au
grand jour de façon établi la commission
charbonneau va changer le québec dans
l'immédiat parce que pour un certain
temps je pense qu'il va y avoir plus
probable en plus de contrôler aussi mais
plus d'auto censure de la part des
firmes qui faisait cette cette collusion
là donc ça va assainir pendant un
certain temps les finances publiques je
pense que ça aussi permis l'arrivée de
politiciens autres que ceux qui étaient
en place qui était soit impliqué afin
qu'on soupçonne d'être un pic il parce
que les procès n'ont posé n'ont pas eu
lieu encore mais qu'on soupçonne d'être
impliqué personnellement dans les
malversations ou un qui est un naïf au
point de ne pas les voir et donc qu'on a
maintenant des politiciens qui semble
beaucoup plus proactifs et beaucoup plus
attentifs